to the freedom tower for kicking off my
block i owe it that freedom tower a
favor
president biden's plan to spend three
trillion dollars on infrastructure as an
astronomical number it's going to get
bigger
unless you're a progressive the far left
of the party wants joe biden to go even
bigger
to the tune of 10 trillion over the next
decade and focused on things like
advanced racial environmental and
economic justice that makes sense and it
seems expensive
uh let me see uh dana last time he had
uh was in control of a
of a stimulus package he gave us car
fisker
which was a disaster it was electric car
it failed we lost uh
528 billion though the e123 battery
system we lost about 50 million
cylinder lost 535 million and what he
learned from that is
i need to spend more an interesting way
to learn from your mistakes am i right
solyndra was one of my favorite stories
of the last decade i wish that we could
bring back the uh we even had a graphic
on the show it was like like a soap
opera of solyndra
that was those were the days look i
don't think that the moderate democrats
want to go down this road of the green
new deal again
one of the reasons that they did not do
well in those house races all across the
country
was that the green new deal was
something that the republicans
could hang on the democrats in moderate
districts and swing districts they do
not like it
the biden team apparently just this
afternoon briefed a bunch of democrats
about the plan that they're going to
reveal tomorrow
one of the big things is raising the
corporate income tax from 21
that's what they got to under trump to
28 percent
well one of the things that we've just
been talking about we just passed a two
trillion dollar bill
to stimulate the economy what do you
think we're going to do to the economy
by raising corporate income taxes
and we just entice all of those
businesses to come back to america
business needs certainty and stability
and you'll see republicans
make that point coming up the the i
guess the formula one is
spend to soar
are you asking me one oh sorry sorry
to get the economy
i think that what they're trying to do
is get the economy to perform i think
that's why you see the economist
all say they are in favor of this plan
of this new infrastructure
it'll result in well i'm telling you
right now you go to goldman sachs you go
to s
p you go to moody's they're all on board
brian they all say that this will
produce
jobs that this will make america more uh
competitive globally and
you know we are right up against china
you know i think in fact
from what i can tell in the senate and
in the house republicans like this bill
because they're in favor of creating
more better highways more better bridges
more ports airports you know high-speed
internet they all like it
but they don't argue about the need they
don't argue even about the price
what they argue about is how you pay the
price
and that's where they say we don't want
to raise price raise taxes on the very
rich remember this is old people over
400 thousand dollars
and 21 to 28 is not bothering the
corporations hey jay not at all that
it was higher under clinton it was
higher under obama and the economy
zoomed in but bothers corporations uh
degan uh
the juan's right there is a need for
infrastructure right but there's a
second tier to this
and it's uh pre-k free pre-k for every
community college and it's a greeting of
the economy
that's not budget that's not bridges and
tunnels no it's not so
raising the corporate income tax rate
there's a lot of research
written about this from 21 to 28
oh now we're higher than china if you go
back to 28
and you take money directly from
corporations
that they would otherwise use to hire
more workers
or pay their existing workers more so
you give
a figurative shank in the kidney to the
kidneys
to every worker in this country by doing
that
and it hurts everybody it doesn't hurt
the rich it hurts working class
and middle class americans number one
and this infrastructure plan
is so laughable pete buda judge has
talked about it
the secretary of transportation he talks
about
putting roads on a diet he talks about
that sometimes you
about removing roads this is the
infrastructure plan i think we need to
subtract
roads we don't need to add a road or
wind one so as james freeman wrote
this is an infrastructure plan that's
not really about infrastructure
just like the 1.9 trillion dollar covid
relief plan
wasn't even about covet jesse what do
you think is going to happen
well i think juan's right republicans do
like the infrastructure
they don't like the extra trillion in
race based
income redistribution and the other
trillion
as a slush fund for green vanity
projects for donors
that's what this is about so biden's
gonna send a half
what like a couple billion dollars to a
green donor
to buy a half and and make a half a
million
electric car charging stations while
tesla's cost about a hundred grand to
drive
no one's going to use them right they're
going to sit out all over the country
and it's just going to remind everybody
visually of the boondoggle
and we saw this happen with barack obama
what he spent
almost a trillion dollars weakest
recovery ever
flat wages solyndra fisker
chevy volt we saw it happen and then
republicans used that as a cudgel
to win back the house right i just said
so and the only reason
that the emissions went down and they've
been going down steadily since 2007
not because of all these green
investments by the government
it's because the shale revolution this
is clean natural gas
that's what's done it he didn't create
any shovel ready
jobs he admitted he didn't and the press
admitted he didn't create any green jobs
either
so joe biden looks at that fact pattern
and thinks
i'm going to double down just tells me
joe biden typical tax and spend liberal
politician
do the same thing get the same results
and keep going
i do think that we do agree on
infrastructure it's a shame no one's
legitimately trying to work out a deal
it's going to be a simple reconciliation
again sadly i think
meanwhile 25